ambulance workers are angry in their own
words they are done
they do an incredible job in the
toughest of circumstances and face real
pressures getting through this cost of
living crisis
our message to the government is clear
talk pay now
instead they've made things worse by
demonizing ambulance workers Who
provided life and Link cover on strike
days
the same people who left picket lines to
rush to save lives the government is
playing politics
playing games with their scaremongering
the people of our country will not have
it public support for ambulance workers
has been incredible
it's clear the only way to resolve this
dispute is to make GMB ambulance workers
a proper pay offer
but it seems the cold dead hands of
number 10 and 11 Downing Street are
stopping this from happening
in the face of government in action we
are left with no option but to take
industrial action
gmb's National ambulance committee has
agreed the following National strike
days
Monday the 6th of February
Monday the 20th of February
Monday the 6th of March Monday the 20th
of March
the NHS trust that will be affected a
Northeast Ambulance Service Northwest
Ambulance Service Yorkshire Ambulance
Service the Welsh Ambulance Service East
Midlands Ambulance Service Southwest
Ambulance Service South Central
Ambulance Service and South East Coast
Ambulance Service
in addition members at West Midlands
ambulance service will be taking strike
action on Monday the 23rd of January
and members at Northwest ambulance
service will be taking strike action on
Tuesday the 24th of January
GMB ambulance workers are determined and
resolute they're not going to back down
it's up to this government to get
serious on pay we are waiting